are you excited are you excited let's
get on with the video
Charlie it's so Charlie yes so Charlie
is so good you do not even understand
how hard it was to pick a winner why did
I even do this
I almost got 100 responses for me to go
through and look at 100 responses and
try and pick the best one
it was literally impossible apart from
the fact it wasn't actually impossible
and I have actually picked a winner but
you know I say literally impossible
because that's slightly funnier anyway
okay so I'm gonna go through my top five
okay number five graver he managed to
copy my video almost exactly you need -
you need my mug which I thought was
really good my mug holds exactly my
amount of tea my mug holds exactly the
right amount of tea why don't you mark I
didn't want to that win because there
would be no point because he's already
got the same mug so yeah okay in fourth
place we have another drumroll please
please
lay three seven six
aren't you happy miles are you happy now
miles this video was very good
stop looking at me and I think I had to
give him some sort of mention just the
fact that he told me he got very very
drunk
making him up video
to be honest your video is the best
video out of all of them and you easily
could have won but apparently according
to your video I'm sure to than you I
need to just get a bit shorter by about
two inches yeah that'll do guys miles is
tiny okay third place we have another
drumroll if I could be bothered y2k John
Richards now this was a couple of guys
who made a parody video of my in the
Apple stool video Wow okay so right now
we're in the Apple store so yeah it was
great they use a green screen and
everything which is top-notch as you can
see we've got a green screen
the only person to use a green screen in
the competition well done to you they
even made our behind the scenes videos
so I could see how much effort they did
thing as you can see our scripts all
right we've got a MacBook Pro thing down
here one of the guys even straightens
his hair to look more like Alex and that
really is commitment it's all very
exciting isn't it it's very very
exciting second place the guy who wins
this amazing Pac Man did a little early
why am i doing the drumroll I had the
sound effect for a germinal second place
is beyond 13 congratulations
now worthless peon thirties video was
excellent
what's that she wanted to see a
reenactment of my reaction not very very
good impression of me and if it wasn't
for the person who came first he would
have easily a one diet coke is better
than regular but person who won their
impression was just spot-on and now we
have the big one gonna have an
extra-long drumroll for this one
ready the winner is
- 868 congratulations Julia hanging out
eating ramen reading about myself in the
local paper as I was watching I was
laughing my head off what's that you
want me to film myself eating this
entire bowl of cereal all right you
insist do you dare me to eat the spoon
you do all right
I've even subscribed to an hour so
there's a little extra ego boost
okay guys I'm gonna try to be serious
for a moment if you look over there in
the video description you will see the
top five videos so if you want to see
the videos in full go over there
everyone was really good and you all did
amazing impressions of me and I would
have picked all of you to win if I could
thank you so everyone for entering and
if you haven't noticed already I have
the coolest teacher in the world ever if
you don't know what this symbolizes then
you have no right to be on YouTube not
to chose between some stay dry and
others feel the pain wasn't that fun
okay that's it yeah bye